- [Narrator] Donald Trump's alleged role
in paying hush money to a porn star
could soon lead to criminal charges
against the former president,
a first in US history.
Exclusive articles The Wall
Street Journal published
in 2018 triggered this
investigation into Trump.
And reporter Joe Palazzolo
is still digging.
- I did not expect five years later
to be still talking
about this case at all.
- [Narrator] As a grand jury
is concluding its investigation,
let's look at the reporting
that led to this pivotal moment
and what could come next.
Let's start in 2016, days
before Trump's election victory.
- [Crowd] U-S-A, U-S-A.
- [Narrator] And years before
porn star Stormy Daniels
would tell her side in Prime Time.
- And you had sex with him?
- Yes.
- You were 27, he was 60.
Were you physically attracted to him?
- No.
- Not at all.
- [Narrator] During the 2016 campaign,
Daniels and her manager
were shopping her story
of an alleged affair with
Trump from a decade earlier.
- She'd been onto successful
celebrity magazines
and the tabloids didn't wanna buy it.
- [Narrator] Michael Cohen,
Trump's personal lawyer
at the time, was also approached
with an offer to buy Daniels' story.
That was in September.
- Cohen says, go to hell, essentially, no.
And then Access Hollywood happens.
- [Trump] And when you're
a star, they let you do it.
You can do anything.
- [Billy Bush] Whatever you want.
- [Trump] Grab 'em by the (beep).
- And then boom, it's like a 180.
Stormy's lawyer is back
on the phone with Cohen
and they're hashing out a deal.
- [Narrator] Daniels agrees
to $130,000 for her story
in exchange for her silence,
and signs a contract
on October 28th, 2016.
Journal reporters caught wind
of Daniels around this time
and over months worked to piece the story
of the payment together.
- So the first story ran in January, 2018,
and it was pretty bare bones.
I mean, what we said is what we knew
which is that Michael Cohen
had arranged $130,000 payment
to Stormy Daniels.
And so we had confirmed
that he'd used a Delaware
Limited Liability Company,
a shell company essentially,
to transfer the payment.
And so those were the two
stories that we reported in 2018
that really got the ball rolling.
- [Narrator] A political
firestorm erupted.
Trump denied the affair and
knowledge of the payment.
- Well, you'll have to ask Michael Cohen.
Michael's my attorney and
you'll have to ask Michael.
- [Narrator] Days later, FBI
agents raided Cohen's home,
which Trump called...
- A disgraceful situation.
It's a total witch hunt.
I've been saying it for a long time.
- [Narrator] Federal
prosecutors charged Cohen
with campaign finance violations
and other federal crimes.
He pleaded guilty to all of the charges,
telling a federal judge at the time
that Trump had directed him
to buy Daniels' silence.
- I am providing the committee
today with several documents,
and these include a copy of the check
Mr. Trump wrote from his
personal bank account
after he became President to reimburse me
for the hush money payments I made
to cover up his affair
with an adult film star
and to prevent damage to his campaign.
- [Narrator] Despite Cohen
implicating Trump in the crime
federal prosecutors dropped the case,
but that still left the
possibility of state charges
as the Trump organization
is based in New York.
Cyrus Vance, the Manhattan
District Attorney, stepped in.
Ultimately, the DA's office
decided not to bring charges.
When Vance retired, the
new DA, Alvin Bragg,
initially decided not to pursue
the hush money investigation.
- There is a felony of falsifying
business records charge
but that requires the records
to have been falsified
to conceal another crime
or to commit another crime.
And, you know, the
obvious other crime here
is the campaign finance crime,
the actual payoff of Stormy Daniels
to protect Donald Trump's campaign.
But there has never
been a case or a judge,
a state judge has never blessed the use
of felony falsifying business records
premised on a federal charge.
In other words, these
are state prosecutors,
they're bringing a state charge
and in order to elevate it to a felony
they have to say that the
crime that was concealed
by falsifying these business
records was a federal crime.
So that's like a weird thing.
And they decided it was gonna be too risky
to bring a case that was gonna rely
on an untested legal theory.
- [Narrator] But then, in January,
Bragg impaneled a new grand jury
to investigate the payments.
He hasn't said publicly
why he changed course.
- Everyone's surprised, frankly,
because our reporting and others had shown
that the office had looked
at this so many times,
had looked at it through
kind of different lenses
and decided each time not to bring it.
The feds had passed up on
the chance to bring it.
So, now, here we are in
2023 and what's changed?
I mean we don't, we don't really know yet.
- [Narrator] One thing that hasn't changed
is Cohen's involvement.
Trump's former lawyer testified
before the grand jury last week
and could be called to
speak with them again.
- This is all about accountability.
He needs to be held accountable
for his dirty deeds.
- [Narrator] Trump has denied
the affair and any wrongdoing,
calling the investigation
politically motivated.
The Manhattan DA's office did not respond
to request for comment.
If Bragg brings charges
against the former president
it could shine more light
on what happened in 2016.
- An indictment's just
an allegation, right?
There are still, you know,
questions that I have
even after having worked
on this for so long.
If the charges are focused on
falsifying business records,
you know, like what did Trump
know about repaying Cohen?
There's a lot of sort
of gaps in our knowledge
about how this all went down.
And then, you know, I'm
really curious to see
if the DA has like learned some new facts.
Charges, if they come, I think
would would sort of begin
like just one more chapter.
(Joe laughs)